hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar small platform enables big
change nanotech assisted discovery of
novel biomarkers for disease diagnosis i
am michelle action of levers and i'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinth the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and is made
possible by an open educational grant
from agilent Edmonton has had no input
in the selection of speakers content or
mode of presentation let's get started
you can post questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your minds to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click on the send button
precious book answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or caring the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen I now present
today's speaker dr. Tony who the
associate professor of the Biodesign
Institute Arizona State University to
learn more about our speaker please
visit the speaker tab at the top of the
presentations window dr. who will now
begin his presentation
hi everyone this is a Tony who associate
professor at Arizona State University
so my team has been focused on that he
was comin toph on nanotechnology for
biomarker discovery and the
quantification in the blood
so today we focus on the triple closest
diagnosis using the line of particles so
why the TB is TB diagnosis are so
important because right now there's a
like one sort of world population still
got infected and the five percent of
them in the highly in a high-risk to
divide that active TV so in 2016 there's
about 10 million people was diagnosed as
new case and 1.7 to 1.8 million people
died by TB and the children is a really
challenging score to diagnose the active
TB and so there's a like especially for
the HIV positive HIV and typically
infected patients and it's the extremely
difficult and so and a TB actually has
been the has been here for like
centuries and we're thousands of years
and why this still so difficult to
diagnose and there's a like we can
diagnose ten million people every year
but there's about another ten million
people cannot cannot be diagnosed
accurately though the although we have
the hundreds of the technology on the
market for TB diagnosis but the
essential concept was never changed and
the doctor always rely on the isolation
in the profile of bacteria from the from
the student and as to go to standard for
TB diagnosis so the such measure is
generally needed a very long term around
time and is Yuri
six to eight weeks to get that final
result and and it's really difficult
because it's really difficult because
not only because they're there low
activity and specificity and also we
have a lot of extra pulmonary in fact to
the patients and also it pediatrics
and for those patients only rely on this
building the collection of this building
is very challenging and and also
recently we have some new technologies
and like a gene expert they can really
speed up the detection procedures and
but the problem is they still rely on
this buildin and also the DNA profiling
from the student can now differentiate
the alite bacterial and the site
bacterial so they have a limited
function in transmitter treatment
efficacy which is also very important
for TB management and we also have the
blood house so the blood has is a highly
desired to advanced this problem and the
current available blood has is a grower
t spot this rely on the long-term memory
of t cells and so the the problem for
those mastered is they can not
differentiate the active TB from a
latent TB so it may be functional for
the divided country but for developing
countries we have to so they have a
large population of the infected
patients and the primary mission for the
clinical doctor is how they can quickly
rapidly identify the active TB activist
that the patients with activities so the
in the 2015 i have chance to attend a
conference at NIAID and the director at
NID dr. Tony Fauci gave the presentation
and the least is three signs the
priority for TB diagnosis and the first
one can we have a drug hit mansard which
is independent which is the independent
of a bacterial isolation for example
like color free and
so that the sanctions that the second
priority is can we have a mansard and
not rely on the use of a sputum and
which can cover all the forms of the
trigger closes like pulmonary and extra
pulmonary and and also the TB HIV and TB
co-infected about at a pediatric
patients and the third one is also very
important can we have a mansard which
can that which can provide the
quantification information in detecting
treatment response okay and so based on
the such neat and we actually build up
that we generated such hypothesis at
first is this straight this very
straightforward and we're trying to
capture the antigen Circuit affirmed to
trigger closest and in the blood so we
actually spent at the almost a year to
device to the ultra sensitive realize
that mattered or immunoassay mastered to
capture those antigen and so even we
capture them and we realized this was
both difficult and that though the why
is so so difficult
there's the two reasons the reason
number one and those biomarkers in the
ultra low concentration in the blood so
the clinical doctor they'd like to use
the the biomarkers as a very low
concentration because they make a stir
the huge overlap bit Yuja overlap
between the the disease group and also
the house group and leading to them that
false positive were fast active and the
reason number two is even you capture
those antigens and in this case we
target two two well-known the MTB
antigens when it sees a sixth but the
other one is there p10 and even you
capture them in the blood and you cannot
make a decision the patients are really
infected by an TB where other natural
your closest micro bacteria for example
like Micah sadly and the mic and so the
in the you
as the end here which is symmetrical
closest microbacterial is more popular
than MTV
so that means even will capture the
antigens from the blood and we cannot
apply them to the clinical use and so
how to address this problem and we
actually further identify the peptide
fragmented in this - to antigens and
which is a highly specific against the
MTB so one from the CRP 10 and the other
one from the ethics so the use of a
peptide can enable us not only to
identify the specific the specific and
antigen from the MTB and also they can
break or dissociate then the bonding
between those antigens with home
proteins the host proteins were that
were there anybodys so they can release
more signals representing those attack
tight and so we have the right markers
and the next one we're setting up the
method here is the place we're using our
nano technology so the better profile
does apartheid and we have to rely on
the use of a mass back and the which
mass bag is the best option for a
clinical application and we select a
multi toss a mass back and but the multi
cause of mass market they have several
limitations including the low
sensitivity and so how to address this
and the we involved we introduce nano
disk to enhance the singular and the
nine of these is made by is actually the
nano porous lady can nanoparticles and
so the why we want to use the nano
porous structure because they have a
they have a allure to the surface area
which can efficiently you reach the
target peptide as showing this a figure
to add a first we have a serum and we do
the very rapid digestion in the
microwave and it's about like 20 minutes
then we got that
in the minute solution now we mix the
digested solution with the nano disk
nano disk is conjugated with the
customized Andy but I've had anybody
doing this a snap the nanopore of the
apply disperse the function which is for
enrichment and the next without without
illusion and we directly spike spot the
nano disk conjugated with our target
peptide on the on the multi target
then Wednesday the laser in the mouth is
shooting on those the nanoparticle and
the 904 will perform the second function
which is called energy transfer so they
absorb the energy from the laser and in
the nano preserve the energy in the in
the nanopore and as efficiently passed
those energy to the tactile target and
enabling them to for better organization
so and by using the nanoparticles and we
can dramatically increase the
sensitivity for those effect added
attraction and as showing this to
spectrum one is a for sale p10 and the
other one is a for ether six okay so the
next step and we're building up the
quantification method so we involve the
isotope labeled peptide as the internal
standard and then we can build up the
standard curve for absolute
quantification as a showing this a
spectrum and you can tell that the right
curve that's representing the TB patient
and the blue curve representing their
house control so both of them is just
showing the peak at a location of a 1603
that's the internal standard but only
the case the TB patient is showing the
peak at a 1593 for therapy 10 and the
1900 for ascetics
that's for the NP be secured to the
antigen attractiveness okay so uh
compared to all other the available
mastered on the market and the nine of
these commands back mazzard is showing
the the molecule advantage the first we
can have the doctor quickly identify who
has the active TB and also the blood
test can cover the different firm of
whatever closest and which is a which is
the point variable and we can be used in
the tracking of the treatment efficacy
and also the we don't and at that time
the
send her to answer time is a weekend
shorter to the two point two and a half
hours and out also the cost the per task
is less than the $10 and so see and once
we set up the matter and we start the
prover II through clinical validations
and first we have a 17 pulmonary TB and
also that 19 extra pulmonary TB so here
that we can be tack the most the case
most the case for different form of PV
infected patients and a house can
there's a 96 house house control and
none of them is showing them the signal
for the antigen tektite so that
specificity is the very ideals and we
also try the pneumonia and 14 pneumonia
patients and there's the two patients
are showing the very weaker signal and
so when we check the medical right
quarter for those patients and the way
we found out there's one patients their
TST result is a greater than this 3
centimeter so in the fun countries in
the Sun can't countries and their CDC
are based on their CDC guidelines and
this patients will be the define as the
TB positive and also we have a 24 NPM
infected patients provided by the NHS
Clinical Center and the none of them is
showing their any single which is
further showing the power of the use of
the peptide selection and so next so we
also compare how we also try to evaluate
how this as we can quickly identify the
active TB from latent TB infected
patients and which is the primary
mission for the clinical doctors in the
developing country so for the same
course with active TB and compared with
31 latent TB infection and there's a for
patients is showing a weak signal and
which is heard of specificity to be
loaded this
the phone number below that 90% but if
you rated at some literature review
literature and the assumption is that
there's like about 5 to 10% of like
latent the IOT belie pages they are
actually at an early phase of active TV
so the this really were say 2 for
further study to evaluate if this IC can
provide the early detection function for
the latent TB and to convert to the
active TB and the for HIV positive and
light and the TV choline fraction and we
have a more faster positive and oh it's
out then the same thing is were say for
a folder exploration and also for the
diabetes latent TB construction we also
have one false positive and so the and
after this we actually started the
Kenneth of more professional clinical
validations and by collaborating with
the local hospital and they collected
nearly 1000 patients and the better
based on the exclusion criteria we
remove than 100 of them and in the rest
the patients there's 95 culture positive
and 102 culture in active patients and
and also 96 the non-tv individuals were
pretty confirmed there's ninety be
infected and in the boast culture
positive and a negative and we have a
different number of a pulmonary and axor
pulmonary TB cases the first we like to
see if this measured can provide the
similar sensitivity in the pulmonary and
acts your pulmonary TB
so the as you can tell and so the in the
pulmonary TB and the IC reach the
sensitivity at 88 percent and in the
extra primary TB cohort and we reached a
90 percent sensitivity so the
sensitivity is a pretty similar in this
two cohorts and the next which is a very
interesting point for the american
country
and so we compared the since it the
sensitivity for this I see in the
culture positive and the culture
negative occasions and in the culture
positive patients we reach the 92% and I
indicate the culture natural patience
would reach the 85% so it's a pretty
visit so the owl hypothesis was
validated and this master visit result
was published under canonical chemistry
the last a year and as the cover story
and and also the father we move further
to validate that is measured in tracking
the treatment efficacy so the local
hospital helped us to collect the
patient samples and in taste and in the
most patients we can detect the
reputedly climb of a blood antigens and
in the end for those patients and so
this is really worthy to forth further
study and to further evaluate if they
can closely track the treatment advocacy
work TB records and and so the next the
next battle is to is against the HIV and
TB choline fraction because in the field
we call this core core life at the
Double Trouble and so we gather some
patients with colon faction with both
pulmonary TB and axial pulmonary TB and
it will reach the decent to sensitivity
compared to the compared to the
traditional mastered and also for the
non TB controls and the specificity is
89% and so one the little very surprised
to us and we found out the blood antigen
level in the HIV and TB Cohen factor
patients is even higher than the HIV
negative
but pv+ patients we explained it is a
phenomenal as by the immuno
press so-so but it's still worth it to
further our to to further study and the
next so we challenged in the mansard who
is the triple strut with which is the
pediatric course and so in the first
group the very small pilot study and we
reached at sensitivity at 82 percent to
100 percent in a different group and
also 100% of for the specificity so once
we reported a study to NIH and they
actually sent us another course and at
first I think that's another pediatric
work world but by closing study that
information and it realized they're
actually in that cohort all the patients
was recruit at a three months old since
they have a HIV HIV infection and so
this including the 635 infant and so
eventually there's a some patients would
be referred to active TB and so it's
perfect core for and also the first
plenty to study we conducted and the
recently the we provide all the results
to to the NIH and all information was
implanted and so we analyzed the
sensitivity and the specificity for a
different group and at the first four
HIV negative group and were reached at
95 percent at 75 percent to 100 percent
sensitivity but for HIV positive group
who reached a 96 percent to 100 percent
sensitivity and all that the end of the
best affinity will remain at a 7 97 to
99 percent so here is that this table is
a showing the comparison between to all
the study i'll measured with others like
cultures mir and skin cast and a chest
x-ray
so yeah the master days are showing a
better sensitivity and specificity and
there's a special case that really like
to
we'd like to present because this is so
interesting and this is single case and
the disc this a child who was a recruit
at a three months old and they're
starting from the wig zero and and and
awake 84 he was diagnosed the tb+
and but since this huge blood sample was
collected every 12 weeks so when we test
his blood sample as a week 25 36 and we
already detect the signal for say a few
10 so it which is 50 weeks earlier than
the gold standard so which can really
provide it is showing the potential of
the this IC for early detection of
active TB so after joining the Arizona
so we further expand this a study to
serve the other pathogens is eventually
for other micro bacterial infraction so
we further develop put another
technology another platform to multiple
provided the multiplexed detection which
using the anti antigen 85 be at the
target but are using the single fragment
based on the teeny-tiny differencing the
the the amino acid sequence and we can
differentiate the five major npm
including and also TV and in the same
spectrum and also we also identify the
specific peptide and Allegiant i'm tight
against the HIV 1 then we can pull right
now we can profile the both HIV one
antigen and also the mtv antigen peptide
on the same spectrum so which is very
useful for clinical management for
patients with korean fashion and and
also we applied this message to serve
another infraction digit disease and
which is a
ebola so so the
we target on the vp40 and also select
the 3-pack tight and which can be
furniture night the five strengths for
Ebola and so that the spectrums showing
on the right side
that's a provided from my by the out
collaborator in the US Army Research
Institute of infection disease and so we
just we cannot have conducted a study in
the lab using the any animal or human
samples so which is a provide our
protocol and to them and they'd have
their the monkey blood they collected at
their site and so that's the spectrum so
using the peptide pattern we can be
first relate desire and student Ebola
and so that's all we'd like to present
today and at last we really like to
acknowledge the contribution from the
our collaborators especially the
combinations collaborators and from the
work light and also the current group
member and other iluminage and also the
active fundings we have many other
fundings but is that they're inspired
but there's only space so for us to show
the active fundings so now i open for
the classes
thank you dr. who for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button
dr. whom will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
why do we need a blood test for TB
diagnosis
yeah so the blood I said as a present so
the traditional master would go to
standard and mastered for TB diagnosis
now is the the sputum culture they were
trying to isolate it a bacterial and
profile them and but the limitation is
there's nearly like a 50% of vocations
in the developing country and you cannot
identify any bacteria in their sputum
and so they're the most of them there
the extra pulmonary tuberculosis and
that bacteria could have located not in
the pulmonary system but other organs
like the bring trigger closest word the
bone tuberculosis and for those patients
is really difficult to identify to to
that to to be diagnosed using the gold
standard and also is really difficult
for children to collect their children
so the student pastor has a summer
limitation and black hat can cover the
most forms of substance of / - the
closest infectious
no matter your pulmonary or acts your
pulmonary and the current available
blood tested can't like a either / t
spot and cannot differentiate the active
TB from the latent and that's why we
developed this method to directly target
the antigen secreted from secreted from
the bacterial in the blood so we can
provide that the Iraq the evidence for
active TB infection
thank you how do you compare your assay
with other blood zero based test for TB
yeah so that we're actually comparing
all I do as many others and some other
Nizer to like it as gene Oxford they do
show the very quick turn a long time and
also the very sensitive the very high
sensitivity in the pulmonary infection
infected patients and pulmonary TB
infected patients and but the short
feature for for the judging expert is is
a difficult for them to attract the
treatment efficacy which would have been
the response because the VNA they're
therefore finding from the sputum cannot
differentiate a live bacterial and died
bacterial and so as we show in the
slider for treatment efficacy the end is
your level is a very sensitive for
treatment so that's it could be the one
advantage
thank you what is the advantage of using
peptides as biomarkers other bed the
whole antigen protein
yeah well we ever used the whole protein
as the biomarkers and we derived the
ultra sensitive
amino acids to trying to profile those
whole proteins but we got to the
problems and one is those proteins
during the ultra low senses
concentrations in the blood and so they
could have the reason they probably the
secretion rate the secretion of those
antigen is pretty is at a low
concentration and another major reason
is the once the antigen present in a
blood they could be very rapidly the
encapsulated by the host protein were
that banquet so their antibody and they
which is actually the hurt the
sensitivity using the immunoassay to
profile the whole proteins and by using
the peptide and as we mentioned the fact
that in action peptide based on the
database and so we actually those
selected attacked Ida is the highly
specific to MTV and not to other NTM so
and and also by the during the digestion
tab we can also be furniture night note
that we can also be so Sinead the
bonding between the antigen and the
antibody and also other hope the
proteins which can release more signals
or release more signals representing the
MTV antigen
it looks like we have time for one more
question what is the commercialization
plan for the assay that's a good
question we actually already have the
company's tablished in Phoenix and in
2018 and at the end of last year we also
have the space bunk and from the
investment and the for advancement and
so so right now the we're working on the
defender milestones and the company is
preparing the to submission and to proc
we will set up the connection with FDA
for approval this this I see this I see
and also the recently without which also
got a sponsors from the TLB and to
further the push forward this IC for
clinical validation we're going to
collaborate with the company and also
the clinician doctors at a better
college of medicine for the multiple
multi-site divided ation and so I would
say probably there for two years and we
may have a dis mastered to serve the
clinical site
I would like to once again thank Doctor
Who for his presentation
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting question
questions we do not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our educational sponsor Agilent
for today's educational webcast lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues to lab this today's live
event until next time goodbye